des coups sur la taille tout c'était 7
sont les places sont d'ailleurs cessé
cela selene le mot le mot qui disait
c'est pour l'instant la date de mai
brandit la tête
j'ai quand même eu des bons coups pour
un usage ce faisant j'ai eu le jouet
freetouch et 2 500 j'ai dû me faire
enlever deux dames après la gorge puis
maintenu au mur solidement puis modifiez
pas personne qui est qu'il est un
caporal lieutenant de cette façon on
loupe ce que je réponds la première non
plus
[Musique]
quand j'écris je me rapproche de plus en
plus de moi même et de ce que j'ai vécu
par rapport à moi
mais ça me fait du bien de me
reconnecter avec moi et ma propre
douleur des migraines à répétition j'en
avais je vais énormément difficulté à me
concentrer je commençais à quelque chose
puis je me demandais ce que je tenterai
de face et au départ sérieusement je
sais qu'une patate c'était quelque chose
[Musique]
la capsule la vie d'un doigt et les
viols que j'avais subi ces locaux qui
ont diagnostiqué une commotion cérébrale
sévère mon choc post traumatique qui
nous est si cher leur expérience
[Musique]
les chiffres mirobolants
c'est effectivement très vaste
proportion de femmes le niveau de la
violence conjugale à leur vie c'est
resté soudé tu dis surtout les séquelles
de cela louis de beaumont nouvelle
[Musique]
lorsqu'on ici à la taille très fort avec
un certain angle le cerveau ce premier
dans la boîte crânienne et allait se
heurter contre les parois la boîte
crânienne
un des impacts plus important c'est
justement sur les accents des neurones
les actions celui des field
communication entre les différentes
régions du cerveau qui tendent à être
plus affectée par les commotions général
parce qu'elles sont étirées et elle se
déchire
il peut avoir une diminution de la
connexion dans le forum différentes
régions du cerveau dont une qui vont
résulter ensuite à une perte
fonctionnelle pour la personne donc
aborder ces quelques années
[Musique]
il me dit il
farina et samedi
[Musique]
par exemple la tête mais mon cerveau
quand même bougerait dans la boîte
crânienne pas suffisamment pour que
j'aie des symptômes d'une commotion
cérébrale mais assez peu taillé pour
faire du dommage si ça manque de
couleurs s'accumulent
[Musique]
sidney crosby n'a toujours pas retrouvé
sa forme et ressent toujours les
symptômes de sa commotion cérébrale
subie en janvier mais qu'il cherche
[Musique]
le truc énorme
c'est toujours demain la gorge choix sur
le lyssois soit au mur mais c'est
toujours deux mains à la gorge qui me
qui m'empêche de respirer j'ai perdu
connaissance ou 20 l'excès de maria la
gorge
est-ce que vous avez une idée de combien
une fois après j'ai perdu connaissance
régulièrement régulièrement c'était
quand même fric
c'est le premier réflexe une femme qui
est victime de violence c'est de
banaliser souvent les violences qu'elles
ont vécu parce que ça fait des amis
qu'elle gibson
ces temps lié avec l'âme
la réponse du système médical qui ne
fait pas le lien de ces traumatismes loc
même quand ils savent que c'est arrivé
en contexte de violence conjugale vous
allez chez le médecin ces 20 minutes top
chrono
alors pour commencer à élargir la
discussion
élargir l'intervention faire du
dépistage
[Musique]
bien
nouvelles fonctions mais qui ne font qu
[Musique]
and held in arrosait elle fanning enso
mais pour nous ça fait la différence
dans notre pratique parce que on est à
l'ère à ce qu'on l'intègre et on va plus
essayez de l'observer puis de voir à
presse avec la femme au québec
est ce que tu veux qu'on est ce que tu
veux en parler à ton médecin ce que tu
veux qu'on t'a company men outils pour
toi finalement qu'on va pouvoir utiliser
au quotidien
on va pouvoir aussi par son neurologue
cette limousine jeu de la chorale
expérience de mastic balance rex been
charged with s'impose à l'esprit de 130
la fatique avec la fatigue ouais ouais
je me sens toujours fatigué des
sensibilité à la lumière et au bruit des
troubles vision ouais je ne voyais pas
bien et se détache
est-ce que c'est flou c'est flou ou et
s'est correctement ça va tout ce que je
veux c'est ma santé
ouais et d'être normale comme avant
on a un devoir en tant que maison
d'hébergement d'investiguer déclaré la
femme puis d'en parler pour essayer
d'avoir plus de soutien pour ces
femmes-là qu'un qu'elle arrive à un peu
partout dans toutes nos tout les
systèmes que je pense qu'il faut qu'il
ya un accueil ou cessent de voleurs au
22 qu'on le fait pour les sportifs il ya
très peu de recherches qui étaient faits
sur les femmes victimes de violences
conjugales qui implique des coups à la
tête
souvent parce que c'est plus compliqué
ça devrait impliquer des facteurs
sociaux beaucoup plus complexe que celui
de la commotion cérébrale chez un
athlète de haut niveau la même façon
qu'on étudie portant les boxeurs on
n'hésite pas beaucoup parce qu'il ya des
fois des enjeux sociétaux semble
complexe que celui d'un athlète en joie
de rock et qui viennent une famille
fonctionnel collègues
cette stratégie nationale va permettre
vraiment d'intégrer les personnes âgées
il faut qu'ils aient de la formation
continue j'étais ici à montréal dans un
hôpital département de gynécologie
obstétrique et j'ai vu des affiches qui
date des années 80 qui parlait de la
violence conjugale les affiches d'été
des premières des 80 85 90 des premières
campagnes de sensibilisation comme je te
passe
[Musique]
la loi
les femmes vont subir des effets à plus
long terme des commotions cérébrales
donc leurs symptômes vont tendre a duré
plus longtemps et à être plus sévère on
commence à étudier pendant les effets
des hormones lors de l'impact en animal
[Musique]
sur les rapports médicaux qu'est ce que
tu écris c'est écrit séquelles
permanentes
donc le travail on oublie ça
malheureusement ça lui semble bien plus
comme un vin mais je dire ça me vient pu
aussi facile comme avant de juste
m'asseoir donc prendre un café
enfin le regard des fois pour dray qui
voit pas la même personne je suis plus
non plus mais j'aimerais que je
souviennent de qui je t'aime
[Musique]
et